FLASH, KOBE, PENNY.
THAT MEANT MORE TO ME THAN
ANYTHING.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE PLAYING
AGAINST HIS TEAM, HE IS A PART
OF MY LIST WHERE I WON'T EVER
FLAGRANT FOUL YOU OR SHOW ON A
PICK.
YEAH.
I WON'T EVEN PLAY HARD.
I ACTUALLY LIKE WATCHING THEM
PLAY.
I ALWAYS LIKED BIG GUARDS.
SINCE MAGIC JOHNSON AND PENNY
HARDAWAY I LIKED BIG GUARDS.
I SAW KOBE AND HIM AND FLASH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW I
KNEW AFTER I LEFT L.A. I NEEDED
SOMEBODY OF THAT CALIBER TO HAVE
A CHANCE AT WINNING.
29, 30, AIN'T GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT BY MYSELF.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT D-WADE
EITHER.
I JUST SEEN HIM KILL BARON
DAVIS.
I AM LIKE I WANT TO GO TO MIAMI.
I THINK HE WAS IN ORLANDO AT THE
TIME.
ORLANDO STILL.
I THOUGHT ABOUT GOING BACK HOME.
BUT THEY WERE STILL TRIPPING.
LET ME GO.
I APPRECIATE YOU.
YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU HAVE
TO FALL IN THAT CATEGORY WHERE
YOU DON'T HAVE A CHAMPIONSHIP,
WHATEVER.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT YOU WERE ONE OF
THE GREAT PLAYERS AND GAVE IT TO
ALL OF THE GREATS.
LOVE YOU AND RESPECT YOU AND
LOVE YOUR MAMA AND FAMILY.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
ONE THING THROUGHOUT OUR
CAREERS, YOU HAVE GUYS AND THEY
LIKE TO LABEL GUYS, HE WORKS
EXTREMELY HARD.
HE HAS A CRAZY WORK ETHIC.
THAT MAN CAN TELL YOU HOW HOW
OFTEN I WAS THERE FAITHFULLY AND
GETTING THAT KNOWLEDGE FROM HIM
AS A YOUNG KID.
GROWING UP.
I AM FROM CENTRAL FLORIDA.
ORLANDO MAGIC WAS MY FAVORITE
TEAM WITH HIM AND PENNY.
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THAT KNOWLEDGE FROM HIM.
THAT WAS VALUABLE.
>> ONE OF THE HOMIES SAID TAKE
CARE OF MY BOY T-MAC.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THOSE CALLS.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE SAID HEY.
THIS IS MY YOUNG FELLA.
EVERYWHERE HE WENT, EVERY CITY
HE KNOW IF HE NEEDED ME I WAS
THERE.
>> YOU GOT ONE OF THOSE CALLS.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE CAN SAY
THEY HAD A PLAY LIKE THIS.
35 SECONDS.
13 POINTS.
>> AS THE COMMISSIONER DON'T
MAKE HIM SHOW ONE OF HIS TOP
HIGHLIGHTS.
>> THEY HAVE SEEN IT.
>> WE ARE GIVING ROSES ON
TUESDAY.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SEEN IT.
THIS ONE OF THE TOP HIGHLIGHTS.
>> WE KNOW IVERSON IS GOING TO
CROSSOVER JORDAN.
MOST OFTEN ASKED ABOUT MOMENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT AND A FEW OTHERS.
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE.
TO DO IT AGAINST A TEAM LIKE SAN
ANTONIO WHO IS A GREAT DEFENSIVE
TEAM.
BRUCE BOWEN, PESTY, HARASSING
YOU ON THE DEFENSIVE END.
TO HAVE THAT COMEBACK AGAINST A
CHAMPIONSHIP CALIBER TEAM WAS
PHENOMENAL.
>> I WAS WATCHING COOPER KUPP IN
THE SUPER BOWL.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO HIM.
>> ONE THING ABOUT THE GREAT
PLAYERS WE GOT THAT WILL.
RIGHT.
THE WILL TO TAKE OVER A GAME.
>> WADE, I TURN IT OVER.
GIVE MR. T-MAC HIS ROSES.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I LIVE BY THE
SAYING AND HAVE IT TATTOOED ON
ME AND EVERYTHING.
MY BELIEF IS STRONGER THAN YOUR
DOUBT.
WHEN I THINK OF TRACY McGRADY, I
THINK OF THAT.
YOU HAVE A YOUNG PLAYER IN THE
SHADOWS OF A GREAT PLAYER AND
YOU BET ON YOURSELF, YOU KNOW.
YOU GOING TO ORLANDO AT THE TIME
I DON'T THINK WAS A POPULAR
CHOICE.
YOU BET ON YOURSELF.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE LIKE BET ON
YOURSELF AND DOUBLE DOWN.
TRACY McGRADY WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST THAT I FELT WHEN HE BET ON
HIMSELF AND WENT TO WORLD AND
JUST BECAME EVERYONE'S FAVORITE
PLAYER, IMMEDIATELY.
YOU KNOW, AS A YOUNG KID AND WE
TALK ABOUT THIS WHEN HE WALKED,
HE LOOKED COOL.
LIKE I WANT TO DO THAT, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE T-MAC WHEN
IT COMES TO STYLE, HOW HE
DRESSED WHEN HE PLAYED THE GAME.
WE ALL WANTED THAT SWAG.
THAT IS WHY WE ALL PUT ON THAT
LEG SLEEVE.
I THINK THE IMPORTANCE OF
VETERAN GUYS.
WE SPENT TIME IN CHICAGO WITH
TIM GROVER, YOU KNOW, DOWN THERE
REHABBING AND GETTING READY.
T-MAC USED TO COME AND DO THIS
HANG DRIBBLE.
THAT IS ALL I DID.
I WASN'T 6'8" DOING IT.
I REMEMBER HEARING HIM ON THE
SIDELINE TALKING ABOUT KILLING
PEOPLE WITH THIS HANG DRIBBLE,
THIS SHOT.
YOU KNOW WHO HE GOT IT FROM?
>> DON'T SAY YOU.
>> ME.
>> THE MEDIA ARE THE ONES THAT
TELL OUR STORIES FIRST.
HOW DO YOU CAN WANT YOUR LEGACY
TO BE DEFINED AS A BASKETBALL
PLAYER?
>> I THINK IT IS DEFINED, YOU
KNOW.
>> DO THE NUMBERS.
>> THERE IS NO GREATER ACCOLADE
THAT YOU CAN RECEIVE
INDIVIDUALLY THAN MAKING IT TO
THE HALL.
I WASN'T FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
PLAY ON A CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM,
RIGHT.
I DIDN'T PLAY WITH SHAQ OR A
D-WADE IN MY PRIME.
NOT HAVING THAT IN MY PRIME, YOU
KNOW, I PUT UP CRAZY NUMBERS AND
TOOK TEAMS THAT PROBABLY WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS TO
THE PLAYOFFS AND PUT UP CRAZY
NUMBERS BUT I DIDN'T ADVANCE.
MY REWARD AND CHAMPIONSHIP WAS
TO MAKE IT TO THE HALL OF FAME.
THAT IS WHY I DON'T GET SO
CAUGHT UP IN HE DIDN'T WIN A
CHIP.
SHAQ IS THE MOST DOMINANT GUY TO
PLAY THE GAME AND HE HAS FOUR
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
IT IS HARD TO WIN A CHIP BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF MOVING PARTS.
GOING IN TO EVERY SEASON FOUR
TEAMS ARE TRYING TO WIN A CHIP.
>> RIGHT.
>> REALISTICALLY TRYING TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
YEAH